in this video we're going to look at
what is the fate of the end product of
glycolysis reaction that means the
pyruvate now pyruvate can be channeled
into Krebs cycle by producing acetyl co
a and thereby citric acid and all the
intermediates of the Krebs cycle
eventually it can go to like the
electron transport chain right and
generate ATP so this whole axis is only
valid when oxygen is present because the
terminal oxygen the terminal electron
acceptor here is the oxygen the
molecular oxygen ultimately the oxygen
accepts the electron and forms the water
and this electron relay is coupled with
proton transport and the proton gradient
is utilized to generate ATP that is one
aspect of or one fate of pyruvate when
oxygen is present but this video is
focused on what is the alternative fate
of the pyruvate when oxygen is absent in
absence of oxygen or in an aerobic
situation fermentation takes place
fermentation ultimately leads to
production of ethanol or lactic acid in
this video we are going to see how
lactic acid is produced now from
pyruvate the enzyme lactate
dehydrogenase converts pyruvate to
lactate acid or lactate and in this
process NADH is utilized and nad is
produced right now NADH provides the
hydrogen or provides the reduction
equivalent for pyruvate reduction into
lactase pyruvate reduction into lactate
now the NAD which is produced in this
reaction is actually fueling the
glycolysis pathway because in an aerobic
situation you can imagine the Krebs
cycle the electron transport chain would
be off right in this situation if you
need energy
you need to fill greco glycolysis but if
the nad is not replenished after after
several rounds then glycolysis would
also stop then where where the cell
would find energy that is why the
fermentation process is reinforcing this
nad levels and thereby fueling
glycolysis and producing energy via
glycolytic pathway the overall
equilibrium of this reaction is strongly
favorable for lactate formation and that
is understood by the negative Delta G of
minus twenty five point one kilo joule
per mole
now imagine a situation of intense
workout in your muscle all the glucose
need to produce energy but wait in very
short time when you need this kind this
amount of energy or this amount of
intense workout is happening then your
blood is not able to supply your muscle
with enough amount of oxygen in that
situation are anaerobic situation
anaerobic condition is evoked or let's
say you're sprinting so initially
glycolysis would produce their energy
but after a point of time the blood
supply is not enough to give enough
oxygen to your muscles but how would you
run in so in that situation we have to
understand Cori cycle so glucose
ultimately gets into pyruvate and
produce energy initially in the
beginning of the Sprint or intense
exercise but eventually that pyruvate is
now converted into lactate and that
lactate replenishes the energy such that
the glycolytic pathway can at least
occur in the muscle and can provide the
muscle with enough amount of ATP but
what is the fate of lactic lactate is
building up in the muscle so how lactate
is metabolized
lactic is actually secreted into the
bloodstream and move to the liver from
liver lactic is reverse converted to
pyruvate and that pyruvate can be
getting converted into glucose by other
mechanisms and that glucose can
eventually fill the muscle again and
thereby reinforcing the whole glycolytic
mechanism and this
known as quarry cycle named after its
Discoverer so now we understand in
anaerobic situation how lactate
metabolism take place and how
fermentation produce lactate in one side
in other side it can also produce
ethanol and that is very important for
these food industry and everything but
in this situation we understood that for
intense workout anaerobic situation is
also created in our muscles and how our
glycolytic pathway is still running and
how the energy is replenished so I hope
you enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a click thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you